so time then for the press preview first
look at what is on tomorrow's front
pages and tonight we'll see what's
making the headlines with columnist at
the article ali mirage and political and
diplomatic correspondent for the
financial times jasmine cameron shalesh
speaking to them in a moment first of
all let's check out those headlines for
you we'll begin with the observer a
warning from world leaders that
afghanistan is on the precipice of an
absolute catastrophe and needs an urgent
humanitarian effort to be agreed
while on the front of the sunday
telegraph tony blair brands president
biden's withdrawal from afghanistan as
imbecilic
that's also the headline on the front of
the sunday times mr blair accusing
president biden of pulling out with
little or no consultation with britain
and the sunday mirror also goes with
tony blair's assessment of president
biden's decision to withdraw u.s forces
onto the sunday express reporting that
the minister for the armed forces says
veterans should be proud of what they've
accomplished despite the chaos in kabul
while the sunday people says that a
record number of britons have offered
afghan refugees rooms in their homes
and i'm joined now by ali mirage and
jasmine cameron jalesh great to see you
this saturday evening thanks for being
with us um ali why don't we start with
you in the front of the sunday telegraph
story actually that's covered uh in all
the papers tony blair has broken his
silence uh the prime minister of course
who uh sent troops into afghanistan 20
years ago
ali
oh sorry jonathan um
well look i was wondering when tony
blair would pop up um
this is uh tony blair who was in
lockstep with george w bush
not only on the afghanistan invasion but
also
the iraq invasion which will always be
his debacle that will always remain his
epitaph what is clear is that the
neoconservative doctrine of regime
change which was advocated by paul
wolfowitz george w bush dick cheney etc
has absolutely and utterly failed now
tony blair is saying that the decision
to pull out was imbecillic i disagree
with him completely i think i think
biden was absolutely right put out the
troops in fact i would argue that the
troops should have been pulled out ten
years ago when osama bin laden was
killed in pakistan back in 2011 however
what is lamentable is the manner in
which the u.s has withdrawn its troops
and the shambolic nature of the scenes
that we're now witnessing uh at the
airport in kabul why the u.s did not
airlift these people out from bagram air
base months ago is beggar's belief so i
think the other thing that blair is
saying is is the west in
in in some sort of retreat uh epoch
changing retreat he says well i do think
that what we what we can see from this
is
that the hegemony of the us
is now in decline it peaked uh from the
decline of the berlin the collapse of
the berlin wall uh until the financial
crisis in 0.708 and now it's in steady
decline and what this is going to show
is and dominic robb himself the foreign
secretary has said this is that we are
now going to be reliant on russia and
china india and pakistan as regional
players in that area to try and protect
our interests china's got its own
interests it's got copper mines it wants
to use it as a part of the pakistan
china economic corridor to put its
assets down to gwadar port in southern
pakistan russia's got its own interests
as it always has had in the central
asian region and particularly
afghanistan so it's a really shambolic
situation but i disagree with blair on
the fact that biden shouldn't pull out
the tricks he should have but the the
manner is is shambolic uh jasmine it's
the same story on the front of the
sunday times blair attacks biden's uh
retreat uh picture there of uh some of
the the troops absolutely exhausted
stuart ramsey our chief correspondent
today
is being reported in many of the papers
actually his eyewitness account of
people he believes being crushed right
at the front of that queue desperate
people trying to get on a flight out of
kabul do you think what tony blair has
been saying is correct
i mean i think he is right in saying
that actually we're at a turning point
now where we no longer have a us that is
focused on nation building focus on
spreading democracy it's now becoming
more you know slightly more isolationist
and we saw this with trump what's been
quite striking is that biden is almost
you know wanting to continue this there
isn't really any appetite among the
american voters for more american troops
on the ground for more wars they are you
know focused on you know keeping
protecting their own interests and i
think
you know we that puts the uk in quite an
awkward position in terms of what that
means for global britain so you know
we've been we've been told that you know
the the uk could still exert its
influence outside the eu we'd still be a
key global player and then as it's
played out in the past few days has sort
of really shaken that and the fact that
rob's conceding that you know we may
have to work with china we may have to
work with russia in order to you know
stabilize the region in order to
actually make a difference i think is
actually quite a striking admission
yeah i mean ali where do you stand on on
where things go from here is it is it a
situation where we just have to accept
that we have to uh form some sort of
relationships engage in some form with
whatever government uh
uh turns up in in afghanistan and also
we have to have very good intelligence
in terms of uh terror training and that
sort of thing uh in the region um is
that the best we can hope for now
well look jonathan i think the the uh
the taliban has clearly hired a very
expensive pr agency or undertaken a lot
of media training in the last 20 years
they're they're giving this sort of
cuddly approachable impression of
protecting women's rights allowing safe
passage people outside the country and
saying that they won't have any
reprisals but the reality is that
there's potentially going to be another
civil war we hope that that doesn't uh
happen but we've got the brother of the
former leader of the northern alliance
ahmed shah massoud sitting in the pancho
valley saying to the taliban that it
must engage in peace talks so there is a
potential for conflict and there's also
a potential potential uh jonathan for
this again afghanistan to be the center
of a new great game it's always been of
interest to outside powers trying to
exert influence
russia has interest there
china already has economic interests
there
and so do india and pakistan and
pakistan in particular um has always
been involved for many many years i mean
it was pakistan that was co covertly
supporting the mujahideen against the
soviets from 79 to 89 whilst the soviets
were there and also left with their tail
between their legs um pakistan has
always been involved and supported the
taliban as well for many years
and has got its own interest i remember
president musharraf telling me once uh
after 2001 when he came to london that
he was going to extract as much bounty
as he could from the u.s before they
ditch us again those were his very word
uh a reference to the fact that the us
pulled out rapidly uh when the when the
soviets uh left in 1989 so you can't
really rely on the u.s and i think what
this shows is
the potential allies of the u.s uh in
other regions i mean you've got to look
at uh china and taiwan
russia now emboldened to potentially get
up to mischief in ukraine what would
happen in that uh in those situations
what what would what would uh what
action would the us allies take and i
think tonight it's very very odd this
week that biden who's the big diplomat
over four decades of experience in u.s
uh foreign policy and foreign relations
as uh first as a senator and then as
vice president has got himself into a
situation where he really has cold
shouldered his ally
in this not even a word of thank uh and
giving a bizarre press conference
earlier this week on booster jabs for
covid of all times so i i think biden
has got a lot of repair work to do in
the coming days and weeks yeah okay well
let's let's move things back to the uk
uh jasmine and talk about dominic rob
more revelations in the papers uh the
sunday times tim shipman uh the
political editor of the uh the sunday
times has got uh what seems to be a good
scoop saying that dominic rob was told
to come home from his holiday in crete
by downing street but he stayed put for
two days uh because the prime minister
said that was okay
yeah i mean it's been a particularly
rough couple of days for rob in terms of
the stories that have come out and
certainly you know it's important for
everyone to have a holiday certainly
everyone to unwind but you know the
problem is is that actually this whole
situation really reflects poorly on his
judgment and johnson's there was clearly
a crisis unfolding in afghanistan and
that's you know he should have returned
to the uk sooner and his argument and
his defense has been you know i've been
able to work from i was doing it
remotely i was still attending cobra
meetings i was still accessible but
actually it's the optics of this
situation that are quite bad at a time
of crisis we want to know that our
senior officials and senior ministers
are engaged you know that they're taking
an active role and leading these sorts
of situations as opposed to you know
potentially being on the beach but i do
think in some ways rob has also become a
scapegoat for many of those who
especially among you know the tory party
who are really angry at you know the
uk's role in in afghanistan at the
moment are really frustrated with how
things have panned out i think there is
a genuine sense of you know both with
the us and uk being almost asleep at the
wheel a sense of how was this taking
everyone by surprise why was the
intelligence not good enough and so i do
in some ways think that rob is getting a
lot of stick for this in a way that it
wouldn't you know it wouldn't have made
that much of a difference had he been in
the uk
in regards to how the events of the
weekend ultimately unfolded yeah that's
a very good point whether he was in
london or in crete uh it probably
wouldn't have necessarily changed the
course of events ali and his job is is
pretty safe now that we know the prime
minister said he could stay on holiday
well indeed but then the prime minister
also said that uh he was full square
behind matt hancock 24 hours before you
had to go look i think rob will probably
stay but it's a very bad week for
dominic rob and what i would suggest is
that the foreign office um discovers the
micro microsoft outlook calendar
function because you have a situation
here where not only the foreign
secretary is away on leave also the
permanent secretary at the foreign
office and the home office as well and
the defense department as well as well
as lord ahmed of wimbledon who's a
thoroughly decent guy don't get me wrong
but again also responsible for
afghanistan and away at the same time so
beggars believed that they couldn't
coordinate their diaries to ensure that
someone was on duty uh when this crisis
was actually unfolding so i totally
agree with jasmine that the optics of
this for dominic rob look absolutely
appalling um i do feel that he has been
made a bit of a scapegoat but quite
honestly in a situation like this where
we're dealing with an utter debacle
people being crushed at the airport
you've got to be seen to be on top of
your brief and he's also come in for a
lot of criticism for the fact that
foreign office staff haven't been the
ones processing visa applications it's
almost been left to uh officials from
the mod to do that where it really
should have been the foreign office
stepping up to manage that so i think
bad week for rob okay and we'll just
finish this uh part with uh the front
page of the sunday express jasmine
because uh
they're looking at um uh i suppose
whatever positivity you can in this
horrific situation never stop being
proud and we have to say don't we that
those members of the armed forces on the
ground in kabul and we've seen it with
our own eyes our correspondent there in
the heart of it they are doing the most
incredible job and stuart ramsey saying
that they're saying to him despite tours
of afghanistan previous tours this is
the worst situation they have ever seen
yeah and i you know i can imagine that
if you are a veteran or if you you know
have been involved in the military you
know the past few days have been might
have been quite triggering and quite
emotional and we saw this for example
with tom teugenhat he's the mp he was a
tory mp who also um serves in the army
and he stood up in the house of commons
on wednesday and he said look you know
this has been an incredibly emotional
time for me as someone that's a former
soldier hearing you know watching the
events unfolding and you know
i do think it is important to
reiterate that actually you know the
work of the army and the soldiers on the
ground is completely is invaluable and
they definitely should be praised and
recognized for their service at this
particularly difficult time in the
region
okay uh don't go away ali jasmine thank
you very much for the moment coming up
after the break the telegraph writes
that boris johnson's plan for nightclubs
to ask for vaccine passports is in chaos
[Music]
hello again you're watching the press
preview ally and jasmine still with us
uh jasmine let's look at the front of
the observer
and back to afghanistan and it's all
very well getting people out isn't it
but of course we also urgently need to
get aid in and that's something the
observer is highlighting
yes the observer highlights warnings
from the un essentially saying that the
country could face an absolute human
catastrophe um it warns of
hunger homelessness um it basically
references the fact that the country
needs more supplies whether that's
medical supplies shelter supplies and
that sort of thing and while i think the
focus at the moment is you know the
evacuations what's happening at the
airport there are also longer term
questions about
what taliban rule in afghanistan will
actually look like whether or not cities
and provinces will have the economic
resources to function and i think
especially as we see you know the us and
the uk like draw militarily i think it
will be crucial that um international
organizations whether that's charities
or the un really do step in and you know
ensure that you know we do avoid the
humanitarian crisis in the region
because all countries whether that's the
uk or the us do have an obligation to
ensure that even though they've left
left militarily that actually human
rights are maintained and that we do
avoid a widespread crisis in the region
yeah um just give me give me one
sentence on this ally and then i'm going
to ask you about nightclub vaccine
passports
well i think i think
jasmine's absolutely right i mean there
is a humanitarian crisis absolutely
unfolding uh it's very very serious
situation thousands of people have been
displaced you can see the chaos at the
airport but the chaos is uh much further
afield as well people trying to get to
the airport there's no way for them to
actually get there so it is this very
serious situation and the head of the
u.n there is saying that we need to get
this humanitarian aid in now before the
snow starts arriving and winter sets in
when it will be impossible
and uh ali just staying with you then
let's turn to the telegraph and talk
about this uh vaccine passport policy um
they're saying it's in chaos this is
about getting uh nightclubs to only let
people in if they've been vaccinated and
can prove it
well this is the the prime minister had
announced in recent weeks that as at the
end of september all night jobs will
require vaccine certification to allow
people in this is a leaked letter from a
lawyer apparently at the department of
health saying that that is not the case
i have to declare an interest here
jonathan and i am a part-time house
music dj and i played my first gig last
friday in shoreditch and um the place uh
the vibe was good but the place was not
ram now that could be because it's
august a lot of people are on holiday
and it or it could be
because confidence has not quite
returned from some punters to be in a
congested environment with lots of
sweaty people dancing i don't know but
from my perspective as a performer
it is something that i support i do want
people back safely in a clubbing
environment uh and therefore i think
look no one likes to id cards or cover
back nation passports but i think it's
just a necessary evil uh to get things
back on track yes a gig i would love to
see ali uh one day soon hopefully
jasmine a thought from you on this
i mean i do think i mean it was a policy
that got a lot of pushback from tory mps
and i think the government is really
gonna potentially run into some issues
when it comes to a getting this through
parliament and also the logistics of you
know working with organizations and
companies to make sure that this policy
can actually be implemented on the
ground and i think when it was first
announced there was that bit of
skepticism about whether it would
actually go ahead or whether it was just
deployed to get notably young people to
take the vaccine so i do think in terms
of the you know i understand the logic
behind it you want to get people into
these venues in a safe way but i do
think the logistics and the
practicalities are going to prove to be
a stumbling block for the government
yeah okay um thank you both very much
indeed we'll speak to you again in half
an hour so ali jasmine thank you